[Music]
[Music]
check your priveledge edition put a
finger down if you have been called a
racial slur put a finger down if you've
been followed in a store unnecessarily
put a finger down if someone has crossed
the street to avoid passing you put a
finger down if you've had some one
clinched their purse in an elevator with
you put a finger down if you've had
someone step off of an elevator to keep
from riding with you put a finger down
if you've been accused of not being able
to afford something expensive put a
finger down if you have had fear in your
heart when being stopped by the police
put a finger down if you have never been
given a pass on a citation that you
deserved put a finger down if you have
been stopped or detained by police for
no valid reason put her finger down if
you have been bullied solely because of
your race put a finger down if you have
been denied service solely because of
the color of your skin put a finger down
if you've ever had to teach your child
how not to get killed by the police any
fingers left that's privileged
people see by blackness before they see
me sometimes before they see me as a
woman or as a human they see my skin I
mean being a black man in America we
were raised knowing that you got to work
harder be nicer
last question like really took me by
shock that you have to explain to your
kids about like police brutality and how
other people perceive you like that's
such a new concept for me that my
parents never ever surely never had to
explain that to me growing up when I was
17 I got pulled over for rolling to a
stop at a stop sign and I was afraid of
getting in trouble but I wasn't afraid
for my life I hope this is a opening to
people that are not black like men have
to deal with this a lot and black women
have to deal with this a lot as well
you have privilege you have the
capabilities of extending some of your
privilege or some of your opportunities
to other people
[Music]